bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale une émission réduite à
13 minutes pendant ces vacances
scolaires on commence tout de suite avec
les informations de la semaine vous avez
dû recevoir dans vos boîtes aux lettres
les fameuses imprimées pour les
déclarations de revenus déclarations que
vous pouvez déposer jusqu'au 20 mai à
minuit sous forme papier et jusqu'au 10
juin pardon si vous déclarez en ligne
l'occasion de faire le point sur la
réalité fiscale dans le département un
reportage de Catherine zolato
les Yvelines ne comptent 738 1179 foyers
fiscaux et parmi eux 68% sont imposables
ces 68% de foyers imposables ont permis
en 2013 au service des impôts de
recouvrer un peu plus de 2 milliards et
demi d'euros certains contribuables
payent l'ISF l'impôt de solidarité sur
la fortune le service des impôts des
Yvelines a enregistré 15197 déclarations
soumises à l'ISF cela concerne les
contribuables dont le patrimoine net
taxable et supérieur à 1,3 millions
d'euros les contribuables ont jusqu'au
mardi 20 mai pour déposer leurs feuilles
papier et jusqu'au 10 juin s'il déclare
en ligne en 2013 44% des foyers
yvelinois avaient choisi ce mode de
déclaration si vous souhaitez des
informations des renseignements le
département dispose de 9 centres des
finances publiques dont un à 50 ans
niblyn qui sera ouvert sans discontinuer
de 8h30 à 16 heures du 5 au 20 mai
après ce week-end de Pâques le chocolat
certainement envahi vos tables
profitez-en d'après les analystes le
chocolat pourrait bien devenir une
denrée rare d'ici à une trentaine
d'années reportage dans une chocolaterie
de Versailles installée dans la cité
royale depuis plus de 70 ans Yolaine
Torres et le Diwan
chaque année les clients sont au
rendez-vous paquet ces fameux chocolats
dans cette boutique de Versailles les
vendeurs s'activent
très bien alors
je voudrais un une vingtaine d'euros
pour certains un peu plus pour d'autres
à chacun son budget pour les chocolats
de Pâques
50 à 70 euros
dépasse pas les 10 euros
c'est pour la décoration de la table un
budget que ces consommateurs devront
peut-être bientôt revoir à la baisse de
plus en plus prisé à travers le monde à
long terme le cacao viendrait à manquer
le chocolat deviendra-t-il un produit de
luxe la demande est beaucoup plus
importante qu'elle l'était auparavant et
si comme ça le devient la Chine l'Inde
je commence à manger du chocolat là le
problème se posera il n'y aura pas assez
de cacao de produits résultat les cours
du cacao flambé cette hausse pourrait
être répercutée sur les prix du chocolat
à la vente certains versaillés affirment
faire déjà les frais mais la gourmandise
est plus forte je me fais quand même une
raison je me prive sur d'autres choses
mais pas sur ce chocolat non j'ai mis
pas mais comme je suis pas un grosse
quantité on peut encore faire face et
après les impôts on va on va voir c'est
pas sûr
à Versailles dans l'ensemble les gens
semblent très attachés à la tradition et
continue à acheter toujours autant de
chocolats de Pâques la gérante observe
toutefois un changement de consommation
c'est à dire qu'auparavant les gens se
faisaient plaisir d'une façon très
importante à Noël et à Pâques pour leur
famille ou leurs amis et maintenant les
gens consomment plus plus
particulièrement pour eux pour offrir
aussi mais pour eux un peu tout au long
de l'année donc ça reste moins
saisonnier ça devient moins saisonnier
au niveau de la vente que que il y a 20
ans ou 10 ans même si elles sont deux
fois moindres que celles de Noël les
ventes de Pâques auraient pesé en 2013
plus de 15000 tonnes en France à noter
que 5 pays produisent les trois quarts
du cacao le Cameroun le Ghana
l'Indonésie le Nigéria et la Côte
d'Ivoire qui détient à elle seule 40% du
marché mondial
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
a traversé une période budgétaire
compliquée deux fois son budget 2014 a
été retoqué la ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche à débloquer la situation en
versant 2,6 millions d'euros d'avance
remboursables ça c'était fin mars la
secrétaire d'État l'enseignement
supérieur revient sur cette situation et
les leçons qu'il a fallu en tirer un
entretien réalisé ce mercredi à
Palaiseau pour les naugurations des
nouveaux laboratoires de recherche de
l'École polytechnique Catherine zulato
et Michael jaheri font le pli fond
pardon mais quand tu pourrais fermer aux
vacances de février en janvier le
président de l'université Jean-Luc
Bessières ne mâche pas ses mots faute
d'un budget à l'équilibre
l'établissement est en péril par deux
fois le budget n'est pas accepté par le
rectorat fin mars le ministère de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche vote une rallonge budgétaire
de 2,6 millions d'euros sous forme
d'avance remboursable l'université est
sauvé mais il faudra continuer à faire
des efforts et fixer un nouveau cadre
concède Geneviève fiorazo la secrétaire
d'État s'en explique lors de sa venue
mercredi sur le plateau de Saclay ce
qu'on a demandé à son président et je
veux il en est d'accord puisqu'il m'a
même remercié de cet accompagnement
c'est de mutualiser des dépenses c'est
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait pas 40
implantation parce que 40 implantations
pour 15000 étudiants ça n'est pas
sérieux donc qui est tout un effort qui
soit fait avec son équipe
d'administrateurs mais aussi avec son
équipe administrative et le tout avec un
accompagnement à la fois du recteur et à
la fois de du ministère encore une fois
ça n'est pas une mise sous tutelle c'est
vraiment un accompagnement pour
redresser l'université le délai ce sera
deux ou trois ans sera le temps
nécessaire au redressement la secrétaire
d'État revient également sur la
responsabilité de l'ancienne présidente
Sylvie Faucheux depuis des misses de ses
fonctions de recteurs de Dijon comme
l'accord des comptes l'a indiqué comme
l'inspection que j'avais mandaté la
confirmé il y avait eu des recettes
surévaluées mais néanmoins français
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait un budget
prévisionnel sur deux ans de 18 millions
d'euros de recettes en investissement en
fonctionnement qui n'ont jamais été
avérés mais quand belle et bien été
dépensée il y avait eu des PPP donc des
dispositifs partenariats publics privés
qui avaient été mal négocié qui coûtait
très cher à l'université que nous avons
dû renégocier des factures n'avaient pas
été recouvraient il y avait eu
l'embauche de 158 contractuelles au
moment du passage à l'autonomie et je ne
vais fiorazo de militer au niveau
national pour un regroupement des
universités et des établissements une
trentaine de regroupements est prévue à
la place des quelques 100 universités
existantes
l'année dernière nous vous présentions
l'avion électrique
IFAN a tous eu le noble la société
yvelinoise et compagnie c'était allié à
Airbus group pour établir le cahier des
charges demain le 25 avril cet avion
effectuera son premier vol officiel en
présence du ministre de l'économie
Arnaud Montebourg à Mérignac cet avion
fait partie des 34 projets de la
Nouvelle France industrielle il s'agit
d'un avion biplace qui peut atteindre
160 km/h en vitesse de croisière sur ces
images vous vous pouvez voir son voltest
il faut compter une heure de recharge
pour un vol de d'une heure c'est un
avion destiné aux écoles de pilotage je
vous propose d'écouter un membre
d'Airbus Group expeads qui revient sur
les origines de ce projet
l'aviation électrique elle est née en
fait grâce au modélisme grâce à
l'apparition des batteries au lithium
qui apportent des rendements vraiment
supérieurs et des performances vraiment
supérieures et grâce à ces batteries et
bien le modélisme donc les petits avions
électriques des petits hélicoptères
électriques ont pu naître et grâce à
cela les petits avions comme celui-ci
comme le Cricri on peut apparaître donc
c'est très récent et c'est vraiment
grâce aux batteries et c'est donc le
développement de ces batteries au
lithium qui rendu cette technologie
possible le nouvel avion électrique
devrait être produit en Gironde d'ici
2016 en quantité industrielle autre
projet industriels portés par ces par
des entreprises présentes dans le
département une voiture consommant 2
litres au sang PSA et Renault devrait
présenter ce véhicule avant 2020 pour un
coup avoisinant les 15000 euros
et enfin un nouveau centre commercial
devrait voir le jour à Coignières en
2015 l'espace Boréal 7700 mètres carrés
divisés en deux bâtiments situés entre
le forum tout juste réhabilité que vous
pouvez voir sur ces images et les portes
de chevreuses il accueillerait
différents commerces alors de vêtements
comme Orchestra mais aussi de décoration
telle maison du monde et des restaurants
les travaux seront gérés par la SOPIC
qui attend pour le moment l'autorisation
de la CDAC la commission départementale
d'aménagement commercial la commune
espère créer une grande zone commerciale
et dynamiser les commerces aux abords de
la N10 les accès à cette route devraient
d'ailleurs être réaménagé pour qu'il n'y
ait qu'une seule entrée et c'est
maintenant le temps de passer à
l'entretien
la Fédération des artisans boulangers
pâtissiers annoncé aujourd'hui le
programme de la Fête du Pain la 19e
édition se déroulera ici du 15 au 17 mai
le but est de faire découvrir et de
valoriser le métier de boulanger
pâtissier l'occasion pour nous d'en
apprendre un peu plus sur cette filière
notre invitée Olivier Girard boulanger à
étant la ville mais aussi président
départemental de la Fédération nous en
dit plus nous l'avons rencontré ce matin
à la Maison de la boulangerie à Chênée
Olivier Girard bonjour vous êtes le
président de la Fédération des artisans
boulangers pâtissiers du département
des Yvelines exactement vous présenter
aujourd'hui la fête du pain de quoi
s'agit-il finalement la fête du pain
c'est
maintenant une institution qui a été
mise en place il y a 19 ans et c'est de
faire la promotion du métier d'artisan
boulanger-pâtissier à travers la France
et au niveau international parce que ça
de grosse répercussions et cette fête
est relayée dans beaucoup de pays
francophones et non francophones quels
événements sont prévus
alors dans les Yvelines cette année donc
le syndicat patronat des artisans
boulanger-pâtissiers des Yvelines fait
un gros un gros buzz on peut dire
maintenant c'est le mois à la mode un
gros buzz c'est de en partenariat avec
la ville du Chesnay nous allons mettre
en place sur sur trois jours donc du
jeudi 15 au samedi 17 des animations
donc la planification du pain donc du
pétrissage jusqu'à la cuisson le
vendredi nous accueillerons les écoles
du Chesnay donc ça représentera 3
enfants on a fait un jeu concours pour
les inciter sur la filière blé farine
pain de faire comprendre que le métier
de boulanger c'était pas juste un petit
carré qu'on voyait chez le restaurateur
un circuit des embouts c'est que le pain
a vraiment ses caractéristiques propres
donc d'être croustillant éveiller les
cinq sens
un accueil pour le grand public un
concours pour les scolaires et puis un
concours finalement avec la meilleure
tarte aux pommes pour les professionnels
exactement alors le but c'est aussi de
susciter des vocations on va faire un
petit peu le point sur la profession en
France et dans le département combien
d'artisans boulangers
pâtissier plus donc on va pas parler des
autres qui ne sont pas boulangers
pâtissier mais qui vendent du pain et
puis sur le niveau national nous sommes
voilà 160000 personnes qui vivent
directement de la profession artisan
boulanger-pâtissier donc les artisans
les employeurs et salariés alors un
chiffre qui est quand même assez
important 10 milliards de baguettes
vous représentez
finalement
parce que il est 100% made in France
oui 100% francilien oui ça c'est sûr
c'est à noter quand même la consommation
est en baisse moins 13% en 10 ans
finalement comment vous compenser ce
manque alors le boulanger depuis 50 ans
a toujours été interactif c'est qu'il a
su évoluer par rapport au mur français
c'est tout simple c'est que maintenant
le take away donc la vente à emporté
représente une grosse partie de certains
artisans boulanger-pâtissiers donc comme
on sait que l'élément principal du
sandwich et puis je veux dire du repas
c'est le pain donc où on retrouve du bon
pain c'est chez l'artisan
boulanger-pâtissier mais comment vous
vous adaptez finalement et bien par
rapport je veux dire au stage par
rapport à notre fédération qui est sans
arrêt entre la culture le fait qu'il
faut se déplacer la formation c'est
comme je vous dis progresser est-ce
qu'il y a finalement de nouveaux modes
de vente par exemple il y a des
boulangers qui proposent de livrer dans
certaines villes certains membres de
commandes par exemple ça c'est une
nouveauté alors ça c'est une nouveauté
mais qui qui ne tient pas parce que je
veux dire le pain est un produit frais
on ne peut pas le balader comme si
c'était bon alors bien sûr en province
j'étais j'ai travaillé aussi en province
donc on a le porte-à-porte quand on fait
quotidiennement mais je veux dire quand
une personne fait du pain le pain va se
retrouver dans des camions réfrigérés
donc il y aura plus sa fraîcheur ah si
ça il sera frais mais ça sera pas sa
fraîcheur de ces sensations organiques
vous adaptez plus en augmentant l'offre
en proposant par exemple des pâtisseries
plus plus de choix exactement la
profession est-ce qu'elle attire
toujours autant de jeunes depuis
quelques années les médias s'intéressent
énormément donc à notre profession à nos
artisanat donc par rapport aux émissions
sur les boulangeries pâtisserie cuisine
la meilleure boulangerie la meilleure
boulangerie que l'on voit cette semaine
à savoir que ça va susciter des
une évocation des jeunes on est relié
par les centres de formation d'apprentis
comme par exemple ici à Versailles à
savoir quand même que c'est la belle
phase de l'iceberg il y a tout un
processus pour venir artisan
boulanger-pâtissier qui est très très
compliqué c'est vraiment passé beaucoup
de temps pour devenir artisan
boulanger-pâtissier à savoir qu'un
patron c'est quand même 15h par jour
presque 7 jours sur 7 à travailler c'est
un cap pour se former alors vous avez un
CAP en deux ans ou un an quand vous êtes
post-bac et puis vous avez différentes
étapes pour venir vous pouvez faire un
CAP Pâtissier après un BTM un bon VTT
des métiers chocolatiers et puis
beaucoup de gens maintenant quitte après
bac pour devenir artisan
boulanger-pâtissier parce que bon ils
ont plus de facilité avec je veux dire
la comptabilité etc pour pour ouvrir une
boulangerie mais à savoir que ça reste
toujours l'intelligence des mains qui
prime quand même sur le fait que on
n'est pas là pour faire du calcul et de
dire j'ai le temps de rentabilité sur
lequel voilà le qualitatif pour moi
représentera toujours les valeurs
essentielles de l'artisan boulanger
pâtissier très bien merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup
et on finit avec l'agenda si vous êtes
intéressé par le télétravail une réunion
d'information aura lieu le lundi 28
avril de 14 à 16h à la Cité des Métiers
à Trappes c'est organisé par l'Agence
nationale pour les volcans du
télétravail et puis la Maison de
l'Entreprise de Saint-Quentin et le
Medef propose un déjeuner d'information
sur la propriété intellectuelle c'est à
dire les marques les brevets le
savoir-faire rendez-vous mardi 29 avril
de 8h30 à 10h au centre technique
communautaire à Trappes attention il
faut s'inscrire c'est la fin de ce fil
écho merci d'avoir été avec nous je vous
donne rendez-vous non pas jeudi prochain
mais mercredi prochain très bon weekend